Not too simple for somebody who has a lot of experience programming, but I think also if I was even just learning a programming language or if this is my first programming language, I think the tutorial's well laid out for a newcomer. Wow, thank you so much. I spent a bunch of time on it, so it's great to hear. welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 159 recorded on November 13th 2023 my name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce we conclude our conversation with Richard Feldman about the rock programming language interesting I don't actually know if that downside does apply in rock so well let me describe the other thing which is the big idea of rock and we'll see if it does or does not well so first of all i actually i'm not sure to what extent people would want to use rock for gpus anyway but setting that aside um so the big idea of the language is what we call platforms and applications. And the basic idea is that every rock program has exactly one platform and exactly one application.
对于一个有丰富编程经验的人来说，它不会显得过于简单；但我想，即使我正在学习一门编程语言，或者这是我的第一门编程语言，我也觉得这个教程对新手来说布局非常合理。哇，太感谢了。我在这上面花了很多时间，所以听到这话感觉太棒了。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 159 期，录制于 2023 年 11 月 13 日，我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持布莱斯（Bryce）一起，结束了我们与理查德·费尔德曼（Richard Feldman）关于 Rock 编程语言的对话。有趣的是，我其实并不确定那个缺点是否真的适用于 Rock，不过，好吧，让我来描述另一件事，也就是 Rock 的核心理念，我们来看看它到底适不适用。首先，其实我不太确定人们在什么程度上会想要在 GPU 上使用 Rock，但抛开这个不谈，嗯，所以这门语言的核心理念就是我们所说的平台和应用程序。其基本理念是，每个 Rock 程序都有且仅有一个平台以及有且仅有一个应用程序。
So if I'm going to build an application, like what we traditionally think of as a program, um, could be a library also, I suppose. Uh, but basically I'm going to pick a platform to build that application on. So let's say, for example, I'm building to pick a platform to build that application on. So let's say for example I'm building a command line application. I would probably choose a platform like we have one called basic CLI which is just a platform for building command line applications or let's say I want to build a web server. That's my application. I would pick a platform that's designed for building web servers like we have one called basic web server. Let's say that I want to build a native GUI desktop application. Again, pick a platform that's sort of good at that. So in some sense,
所以，如果我要构建一个应用程序——就像我们传统上认为的程序一样，我想它也可以是一个库。不过，基本上我要选择一个平台来构建该应用程序。比方说，我要选择一个平台来构建该应用程序。假设我正在构建一个命令行应用程序。我可能会选择一个平台，比如我们有一个叫 basic CLI 的平台，它只是一个用于构建命令行应用程序的平台；或者假设我想构建一个网页服务器。这就是我的应用程序。我会选择一个专为构建网页服务器而设计的平台，比如我们有一个叫 basic web server 的平台。假设我想构建一个原生的 GUI 桌面应用程序。同样，选择一个在这方面比较擅长的平台。所以在某种意义上，
a platform from an application author's perspective feels like picking kind of like a framework. It's like just a starting point. It's like this is something domain specific. It's like this is going to give me the tools that I need to build whatever thing I'm going to build. What's different between Rock platforms and your traditional framework is what is in scope for them. So traditionally, in most languages, C++ included, in your standard library, you have a bunch of IO operations, as well as data structures and math and stuff like that. And then if you're using a framework for something, it's kind of like as a nice to have on top of standard library stuff. It gives you sort of like more that's like maybe domain specific. And also your memory management stuff and like C++ is all going to be kind of
从应用程序作者的角度来看，选择平台感觉就像是选择某种框架。它就像是一个起点。它就像是特定于领域的。它就像是能为我提供构建我将要构建的任何东西所需的工具。Rock 平台与传统框架的区别在于它们的适用范围。通常情况下，在大多数语言中（包括 C++），在你的标准库中，你会有一堆 I/O 操作，以及数据结构、数学运算之类的内容。然后，如果你为某些事情使用框架，它有点像是标准库之上的锦上添花。它会为你提供更多可能特定于领域的内容。而且你的内存管理之类的内容，比如在 C++ 中，都将是
separate. You can do that however you want. Now in Rock, what's in scope for a platform is, yeah, it's all the domain specific stuff. So like a web server is going to have a way to do like HTTP, it's going to have a way to do, you know, handle requests and turn them into responses. But also the platform is responsible for providing all of your IO primitives. So the rock standard library doesn't have any IO in it at all doesn't even know how to do it. It's just like, it's just 100% data structures. So all that comes from your platform. Separately, the platform is also responsible for memory management so if i were to write a platform like for i'll give the easy example of web server the basic web server platform so rock does automatic reference counting that's kind of the
各自独立的。你可以随心所欲地处理这些。现在在 Rock 中，平台的适用范围包括所有特定于领域的内容。比如网页服务器将拥有处理 HTTP 的方法，将拥有处理请求并将其转化为响应的方法。但同时，平台还负责提供你所有的 I/O 原语。所以 Rock 的标准库中根本没有任何 I/O，它甚至不知道该怎么做。它只是，它完全就是 100% 的数据结构。因此，所有这些都来自于你的平台。除此之外，平台还负责内存管理。所以如果我要编写一个平台——我举一个简单的网页服务器的例子，即 basic web server 平台——Rock 采用的是自动引用计数，这算是
default memory management system but the platform is actually comprised of two pieces one is the sort of public facing Rock API. But the other part is something implemented in a lower level language than Rock that sits beneath that, that is responsible for actually implementing the like IO primitives and basically all the like low level stuff that you would normally associate with like a language runtime, including memory management. So the way that that works is essentially, if I'm writing my rock application, every time that application needs to allocate some memory, the rock compile
默认的内存管理系统，但平台实际上由两部分组成。一部分是面向公众的 Rock API。而另一部分则是在 Rock 底层语言中实现的内容，它位于 API 下方，负责实际实现 I/O 原语，以及你通常与语言运行时（包括内存管理）相关联的所有底层东西。其工作原理基本上是：如果我在编写 Rock 应用程序，每当该应用程序需要分配一些内存时，Rock 编译器
is going to generate a call to a function that's implemented in the platform somewhere called rock underscore alloc. So it's basically like malloc. And whenever the reference count gets to zero, it's going to call rock dealloc, which also is implemented in the platform. So here's an example of what's cool about this. Let's say I'm building on the basic web server platform. I happen to know that basic web server just does kind of your traditional malloc and free. So it basically just feels like a normal automatic reference counting system. Fine.
就会生成一个调用，该调用指向平台中某处实现的名为 `rock_alloc` 的函数。所以它基本上就像 `malloc`。每当引用计数归零时，它就会调用 `rock_dealloc`，这个函数也是在平台中实现的。所以这里有一个例子，展示了这有多酷。假设我正在基于 basic web server 平台进行构建。我恰好知道 basic web server 使用的只是一种传统的 `malloc` 和 `free`。所以它基本上感觉就像一个普通的自动引用计数系统。很好。
There's a work in progress web server platform that is planned to be API compatible with that basic web server one. So if you've built something on top of the basic web server platform, you could just try switching to this and see how you like it. But its main selling point is that instead of using malloc and free, it bump allocates on a per request basis. So if you have a request handler, your request comes in, that entire request is going to be doing bump allocation into an arena that's specific to that request for the entire duration of the request. It's not going to free anything. And then once you get to the end of the request and you've sent the response back, it's just like, cool, we'll just reset the arena
目前有一个正在开发中的网页服务器平台，计划实现与那个 basic web server 平台的 API 兼容。因此，如果你已经在 basic web server 平台之上构建了某些东西，你只需尝试切换到这个新平台，看看你是否喜欢它。但它的核心卖点是，它不使用 `malloc` 和 `free`，而是按每个请求进行 bump allocation（指针碰撞分配）。因此，如果你有一个请求处理程序，当请求到来时，在整个请求的持续时间内，该请求的所有内存分配都将通过 bump allocation 放入一个专属于该请求的内存 arena（区域）中。它不会释放任何东西。然后，一旦你到达请求的结束阶段并将响应发送回去，它就会觉得：太棒了，我们只需重置这个 arena
and then move on. And you also set, you say like, here's how much memory I want to allocate to each request. Each request gets this big of an arena. And if any individual request exceeds that, then you get a 500 error and nothing else happens to the rest of the in-flight requests. So this has like a number of cool properties. One of which is obviously it's, we assume, going to be faster than like managing a free list and stuff like that. Like bump allocation and deallocation is like about as fast as it gets in terms of memory management strategies for heap allocations. But secondly, it also means that you get this really nice granular control over memory limits on a per request basis, rather than, for example, saying like, you know, this entire server has this
然后继续前进。你还可以设定：我希望为每个请求分配这么多的内存。每个请求都会获得这么大的一块 arena。如果任何单个请求超出了该限制，你就会得到一个 500 错误，而其余正在处理中的请求则完全不受影响。因此，这具有许多很酷的特性。其中之一显而易见，我们假设它会比管理空闲链表（free list）之类的东西更快。比如，就堆分配的内存管理策略而言，指针碰撞的分配和释放几乎是最快的。但其次，这也意味着你可以对每个请求的内存限制进行非常精细的控制，而不是像以前那样，例如说“整个服务器有这个
memory limit. And if we go over that, then, you know, maybe like something bad happens to the other requests that are in flight, etc. It's sort of very narrowly scoped and sort of isolates. If something is misbehaving or using way more resources than we anticipated, it's really limited to just that one request handler and nobody else's experience is affected. So that's something that I don't know of any other automatically memory managed language where you can do something like that. When, when, um, uh, can you write a rock application where like, do you write code that is platform agnostic? Um, or do you write code specifically to apply? Well, if I'm writing an application, it's yeah, it's going to be for that particular platform. Um, but I guess the better answer is you can do both. So certainly we expect libraries in the ecosystem to be almost all platform agnostic.
内存限制”，如果我们超出了这个限制，那么，你知道的，可能会对其他正在处理的请求产生不良影响，等等。它的范围被限定得非常狭窄，并且起到了隔离作用。如果某个组件行为异常或使用了远超预期的资源，它真的只会局限于那单个请求处理程序，而不会影响其他任何人的体验。因此，据我所知，在其他任何自动内存管理的语言中，你都无法做到这一点。当……当，呃……你能编写一个平台无关的 Rock 代码吗？呃，还是说你编写的代码是专门针对特定应用的？嗯，如果我正在编写一个应用程序，是的，它将是针对那个特定平台的。嗯，不过更好的回答是，你两者都可以做。当然，我们期望生态系统中的库几乎全部都是平台无关的。
We have a plan, and this is something that's not implemented yet, but a design, I should say, for how to make it so that you can write platform agnostic I.O. packages, like things that depend on I.O. but don't depend on any particular platform's implementation of that I.O. They just say, like, I depend on IO, but don't depend on any particular platform's implementation of that IO. They just say like, I depend on HTTP. It, you know, we have a common understanding of what HTTP IO means across multiple platforms. And as long as you're using a platform that provides that, cool, you can use this package for, you know, error reporting or something like that. So we have a plan for all that, but that's not, that doesn't exist yet. That's still the designed but not implemented stage. So the cool part about this to for all that, but that's not, that doesn't exist yet. That's still the designed but not implemented stage.
我们有一个计划——这还是一个尚未实现的功能——但这是一个设计方案，旨在让你能够编写平台无关的 I/O 包，比如那些依赖 I/O 但不依赖任何特定平台的 I/O 实现的代码。它们只是说：“我依赖 I/O，但不依赖任何特定平台的 I/O 实现。它们只是说：我依赖 HTTP。你知道的，我们对多个平台上的 HTTP I/O 意味着什么有着共同的理解。只要你使用的是提供该功能的平台，太棒了，你就可以将此包用于错误报告之类的事情。”所以我们对所有这些都有一个计划，但这还不存在。这仍然处于设计阶段，尚未实现。所以对此来说很酷的部分是……对所有这些都有一个计划，但这还不存在。这仍然处于设计阶段，尚未实现。
So the cool part about this to me is that it means that as an application author, I get a user experience that's quite familiar. I'm like, oh yeah, okay, I choose this. It's not called a framework, but it's, you know, something similar to that, that like it's domain specific and I'm going to use as my starting point to build on. Maybe it feels a little bit weird that my IO primitives don't come from the standard library, but rather they, you know, come from there, but like, whatever, that's not very different.
所以对我来说，这其中最酷的部分在于，作为应用程序作者，我能获得一种非常熟悉的的用户体验。我会想：“哦，是的，好的，我选择了这个。”它不叫框架，但你知道，它类似于那种特定于领域的东西，我将把它作为构建的起点。也许我的 I/O 原语不是来自标准库，而是来自其他地方，这感觉可能会有点怪异，但管他呢，这其实没太大区别。
It's just like, where am I importing them from? But then you just sort of automatically get these cool benefits in terms of like, you know, memory management. And another really interesting one, which is a whole long tangent is security. So one of the things you can do with this is somebody can implement a platform called, let's call it like SafeScript. And basically the
它只是我从哪里导入它们的问题而已。但随后，你就会在内存管理等方面自动获得这些很酷的好处。另一个非常有趣的点——这是一个很长的题外话——就是安全性。所以你可以用它做的一件事是，有人可以实现一个平台，我们暂且称之为 SafeScript。基本上，
idea here is it's like, this is a command line application where the feature is anytime the rock program that you're running on this platform tries to do any kind of IO, it will prompt you, like say, hey, this rock program wants to read from slash Etsy slash password. Do you want to allow that? Yes or no. Um, this wants to write to this folder and, you know, on your, on your hard drive. Do you want to allow that? This wants to do this network request to this URL. Do you want to allow that? Um, and the purpose of this would be, I'm sure you guys have had this experience, but like, you know, you download some program from the internet and it's like, Hey, this is going to do a convenient thing for you. And I'm like,
这里的想法是：这是一个命令行应用程序，其特点是每当你在这个平台上运行的 Rock 程序尝试进行任何类型的 I/O 时，它都会提示你，比如：“嘿，这个 Rock 程序想要读取 `/etc/passwd`。你想要允许这样做吗？是或否。”“这个想要写入你硬盘上的这个文件夹。你想要允许这样做吗？”“这个想要对这个 URL 发起这个网络请求。你想要允许这样做吗？”嗯，这样做的目的是——我确信你们都有过这种经历——你知道，你从互联网上下载了一些程序，然后它会说：“嘿，这将为你做一件很方便的事情。”而我会想：
cool. Or it's going to destroy my, you know, computer or turn it into a bot or like, you know, install something that I don't want installed. Um, there's, there's really no nice way to verify that like something that you download from the internet is not doing something malicious. Like kind of the state of the art is like either like run it through some sort of third party checker that hopefully will tell you whether it's legit or not or inspect all the source code and the source code of all of its dependencies yourself, which is like nobody does.
太酷了。或者它会摧毁我的……你知道的……电脑，或者把它变成一个僵尸网络，或者安装一些我不想安装的东西。嗯，实际上没有什么好方法来验证你从互联网下载的东西是否没有做恶意的事情。目前的尖端技术水平基本上要么是：通过某种第三方检查器运行它，希望它能告诉你这是否合法；要么是你自己检查所有的源代码以及它所有依赖项的源代码，而这基本上……没有人会这么做。
So the cool part about this is that if you have this, a platform like that, you can verify something you downloaded from the internet just by looking at like the one line of like what platform is it using. And if I know that that platform is the one that does the prompting, then I'm like, cool, I don't have to trust this thing because it's going to be like I'm running it in the browser where like anytime it tries to do anything that could possibly harm my system, it's going to prompt me. And because the platforms are in charge of 100% of IO and there's no workaround for that there's no like escape hatch that lets you get around that in the language I know with 100% certainty that it's like yeah if it tries to do anything malicious like I'm gonna
所以这其中最酷的部分是，如果你拥有这样一个平台，你只需看一眼它使用的是什么平台这一行代码，就可以验证你从互联网下载的东西。如果我知道那个平台是会进行提示的那一个，那么我就会想：“太酷了，我不必信任这个东西，因为它就像是在浏览器中运行它一样，每当它试图做任何可能损害我系统的事情时，它都会提示我。”由于平台负责 100% 的 I/O，并且没有绕过这一点的变通方法，语言中也没有任何“逃生舱”能让你绕过这一点，因此我有 100% 的把握确定——是的，如果它试图做任何恶意的事情，我都会
get a prompt and I'm gonna find out about it I'm gonna have to approve that before it can do the thing um that's also something which I don't know I think the closest I have heard of any language doing something like that is Deno and uh you you know, again, without going on a big tangent, like they don't really do it in that granular of a way. Interesting. Yeah, it's interesting. I've heard this on your podcast because you've talked about people that are more familiar with security. And, I mean, it sounds like it's offering, like Rock is going to be offering more than like any other language in this space in terms of... Was that your motivation for the platform's concept?
收到提示，我会发现它，在它执行该操作之前我必须批准它。嗯，这也是一件事，我不知道……我想我听说过任何语言做类似事情的最接近的例子是 Deno，而且……你知道，同样地，不用扯得太远，它们实际上并没有以那种如此精细的方式来做这件事。有趣。是的，这很有趣。我在你的播客上听到过这个，因为你谈论过那些对安全性更熟悉的人。我的意思是，听起来它提供的功能——Rock 将在……方面提供比该领域的任何其他语言更多的功能。这难道就是你提出平台概念的动机吗？
Like what was your original motivation for the platform concept? That's a great question. So it actually wasn't security at all. I just kind of realized that partway through. The original motivation was actually just that, so I'm a big fan of the Elm programming language. Before I got into Rock, I spent quite a few years doing Elm and really loving it. I wrote a book about it called Elm in Action from Manning. I taught courses on it.
就像你最初提出平台概念的动机是什么？这是一个很好的问题。所以实际上这根本不是出于安全考虑。我只是在进行到中途时才意识到这一点。最初的动机其实只是——我是 Elm 编程语言的超级粉丝。在接触 Rock 之前，我花了好几年时间使用 Elm 并且非常喜欢它。我写过一本关于它的书，由 Manning 出版社出版的《Elm in Action》。我教过关于它的课程。
I spent more than 100 hours personally standing in front of classrooms teaching beginners elm um and uh the reason that that like i felt motivated to start rock was basically wanting a language that had an elm-like feel to it but which could be used in sort of the long tail of domains like elm is a very domain specific language it's like really focused on like building browser-based uis and if and when it expands to other domains evan's approach is to like, look at that domain and try to answer the question, like, how can we do a really, really great job, like, you know, supporting this domain in this language, and that could potentially mean making language changes to do that. And so there's naturally this sort of long tail of use cases that Elm is never
我亲自花了一百多个小时站在教室里教初学者 Elm。而且……促使我开始着手开发 Rock 的原因，基本上是想要一门具有 Elm 风格、但可以用于各种长尾领域（long tail of domains）的语言。Elm 是一门非常特定于领域的语言，它非常专注于构建基于浏览器的 UI。如果它扩展到其他领域的化，埃文（Evan）的方法是审视那个领域，并试图回答这样的问题：我们如何才能在这个语言中非常、非常出色地支持这个领域？而这可能意味着需要对语言进行更改来实现这一点。因此，自然会存在一长串 Elm 永远不会
going to address, like Elm itself. Examples that come to mind are things like editor extensions. Like I was using Vim for a long time and I was always like, I would like to write my own extension, but I don't want to do Vim script. Like Vim script does not have a good reputation in terms of like user friendliness. I would really love to use Elm or an Elm-like language for that, or like database extensions or, you know, robotics, making a clock. Like there's just all these things where it's like elm's never gonna get into that domain and so i wanted a language that could try to recreate the elm like experience but for all these domains one of the things that
涉足的用例长尾，比如 Elm 本身。浮现在脑海中的例子有编辑器扩展。比如我用 Vim 用了很长一段时间，我总是想：“我想编写我自己的扩展，但我不想用 Vim 脚本。”Vim 脚本在用户友好性方面的名声并不好。我真的很想为此使用 Elm 或类似 Elm 的语言，或者像数据库扩展，或者……你知道的，机器人技术，制作一个时钟。有太多这样的事情，Elm 永远不会进入这些领域，所以我想要一门能够尝试重现 Elm 般的体验，但适用于所有这些领域的语言。我认为
i think is key to the the niceness of elm is that for a given domain elm is like look here's all the primitives that make sense in this domain. Like you don't have, like in the browser, for example, you don't have like file system stuff like Elm just doesn't have any file APIs because you don't have files in the browser. In contrast, like I know that you can use Rust in the browser, like there's a package called u-y-e-w that is for like building user interfaces on WebAssembly and Rust in the browser. But of course, like in the Rust standard library, there's a whole module on file system stuff. Like if I'm depending on a third party library that does a bunch of file system
Elm 的美妙之处的关键之一在于，对于给定的领域，Elm 的态度是：“看，这里有在这个领域中所有合乎情理的原语。”比如你没有——就像在浏览器中一样，你没有文件系统之类东西，Elm 根本没有任何文件 API，因为你在浏览器中没有文件。相比之下，我知道你可以在浏览器中使用 Rust，有一个叫做 yew 的包，用于在浏览器中的 WebAssembly 和 Rust 上构建用户界面。但当然，在 Rust 标准库中，有一整块关于文件系统的内容。如果我依赖一个执行大量文件系统操作的第三方库，
stuff, I don't even know what's going to happen if I use that in the browser. I also don't even know which of my dependencies like are going to do that or are going to rely on that functionality being there if i try to use them as dependencies in my browser-based project um so the whole ecosystem in uh in in most languages is sort of let's assume that like everything is available even though it might not be i have similar questions about like database extensions like if i'm writing a database extension i don't want that thing to be doing arbitrary network requests or like HTTP in the middle of my database. That's that's like not good for such a performance sensitive environment.
我甚至不知道如果我在浏览器中使用它会发生什么。我甚至不知道我的哪些依赖项会这样做，或者如果我尝试将它们用作我基于浏览器的项目的依赖项，它们是否会依赖该功能的存在。所以……在大多数语言中，整个生态系统基本上都是假设所有东西都是可用的，即使它可能并非如此。我对数据库扩展也有类似的问题——如果我正在编写一个数据库扩展，我不希望那个东西在我的数据库中间执行随意的网络请求或 HTTP。这对于这样一个对性能敏感的环境来说是……不太好的。
So and likewise, you know, if I'm running like a little, you know, servo thing on a Raspberry Pi, maybe it's not connected to the Internet. Like what if I'm using a dependency that relies on doing a network connection. So basically, I really wanted to try to recreate that sort of domain-specific focus while still addressing the long tail of domains. And this was the solution I came up with, was just to say each individual domain, somebody can create their own little Elm-like experience in that domain using a platform.
同样地，你知道的，如果我正在树莓派上运行一个小型伺服（servo）程序，它可能没有连接到互联网。如果我使用的是依赖于网络连接的依赖项怎么办？所以基本上，我真的想尝试重现那种特定于领域的焦点，同时仍然解决领域的长尾问题。这就是我想出的解决方案，那就是：让每个人都可以在每个特定领域中，使用平台创建他们自己的微型类 Elm 体验。
They can say, here are the primitives that are available that I think make sense in this domain, in this use case. And, you know, here's the memory management strategy that I think makes sense for this use case. And, you know, they can sort of be in charge of that. And as a user, I don't necessarily need to think about like, oh, what can't I use here? It's just like, oh, well, just I picked my platform
他们可以说：“这里是可用的原语，我认为它们在这个领域、这个用例中是有意义的。”并且，“这里是我认为对这个用例有意义的内存管理策略。”并且，你知道的，他们可以负责这些事情。而作为用户，我不一定需要去思考：“哦，这里有什么是我不能用的？”只需像：“哦，好吧，我选择我的平台，
and that's all the stuff I can use is there and all the stuff that, you know, doesn't make sense in this domain just isn't available. And so there's not really anything to think about. So, but like, so you can only use one platform at a time. Yes. Everybody asks that. Okay. But what if I want to use two platforms? So, I mean, the short answer is that it's actually fascinating to me that this is like a ubiquitous question. Whenever I describe this, everybody's like...
我能使用的所有东西都在那里，而所有在这个领域中没有意义的东西只是不可用。”所以基本上没有什么需要思考的。所以，但是……你一次只能使用一个平台吗？是的。每个人都会问这个问题。好的。但是如果我想使用两个平台呢？所以，简短的回答是，对我来说真正迷人的是，这是一个无处不在的问题。每当我描述这一点时，每个人都会说……
So actually, a common way that people phrase it is like, can I compose platforms? So let me describe how platforms actually work under the hood. And then I think you can maybe see why the question doesn't doesn't have like a reasonable answer so literally what's happening is that rock itself actually compiles down to basically the equivalent of a c library like just an object file um it just exposes a bunch of functions that's it rock is not in charge of like main or you know start in the like in the binary um rock is just like here's a bunch of functions the platform is actually in charge of main the platform is like i have you know my c program or my rust or whatever you're using to
所以实际上，人们常说的表述方式是：我可以组合平台吗？让我来描述一下平台在底层是如何实际工作的。然后我想你大概就能明白为什么这个问题没有一个合理的答案了。字面上的情况是：Rock 本身实际上被编译成了基本上等同于 C 库的东西——仅仅是一个目标文件（object file）。它只是暴露了一堆函数，仅此而已。Rock 不负责 `main` 函数，也不负责二进制文件中的 `start`……Rock 只是说：“这里有一堆函数。”平台实际上负责 `main`。平台会说：“我有我的 C 程序，或者 Rust，或者你用来
implement the low level stuff um and you have main and then at some point you call the rock function and the rock that that sort of kicks everything off from the rock perspective so another use of rock by the way because of this is like you can embed it in like a very large other project. So you could use it as like a Lua alternative and like a game engine or something like that if you wanted to. But because of that, it's like, well, how would you have multiple platforms? That's like saying like, how would you have multiple mains in an executable? It's like, well, you can't, there's like, there's only one starting point. That's the whole point. So because the platform is in charge of all that stuff um it just doesn't really make sense to have more than one you know competing executable inside your one executable that makes sense but like what if i so like
实现底层逻辑的任何东西，并且你拥有 `main`。”然后在某个时刻，你调用 Rock 函数，从 Rock 的角度来看，这会启动一切。顺便说一句，正因为如此，Rock 的另一个用途是：你可以将它嵌入到一个非常大的其他项目中。如果你愿意的话，你可以将它用作游戏引擎等场景中的 Lua 替代品。但正因为如此，这就成了：“嗯，你怎么能拥有多个平台呢？”这就像是在问：“你怎么能在可执行文件中有多个 `main` 函数呢？”答案是：嗯，你不能，只有一个起点。这正是重点所在。因此，由于平台负责所有这些事情，
like you mentioned uh a command line platform in a like a web server platform right like what if i wanted to have some sort of command line tool that has a web server inside of it? Would I need a separate platform for that? That's a good question. I mean, so not necessarily. It just kind of depends on how you want to have things set up. So for example, in our command line tool,
拥有一个以上相互竞争的可执行文件在你的单一可执行文件内部，确实说不通。这说得通，但是如果我……比如，你提到了……呃，命令行平台和网页服务器平台，对吧？如果我想拥有某种内置网页服务器的命令行工具呢？我需要为此准备一个单独的平台吗？这是一个好问题。我的意思是，不一定。这完全取决于你希望如何设置。例如，在我们的命令行工具中，
we do have TCP socket support. So just using that, you can just build a web server on top of that in pure rock if you want to there's nothing stopping you from doing that what you won't get is you won't get the like bump allocated per request experience that you get if you get like a um uh yeah but now another thing to note is that depending on what you're using it for like so actually i actually have run into that at work before um that that exact use case and it was specifically for doing um like an oauth authentication flow where you needed to like stand up a web server locally and then the thing you're authenticating with would go hit that um but i think there's actually a pretty
我们确实拥有 TCP 套接字支持。因此，只需使用它，如果你愿意的话，你完全可以用纯 Rock 在其之上构建一个网页服务器，没有任何东西会阻止你这样做。你将无法获得的是：你无法获得如果你使用某个……嗯……那种按请求进行 bump allocated（指针碰撞分配）的体验。是的，但现在要注意的另一件事是，根据你使用它的目的——实际上，我在工作中以前确实遇到过那个确切的用例，它专门用于执行……比如 OAuth 认证流程，你需要就地启动一个网页服务器，然后你正在进行认证的东西会去访问它。
good reason that you wouldn't just want to always just use this you know command line tool that um like in addition to missing out on the potential um you know bump allocation benefits on the request handlers um which is that like i kind of don't want my web server typically if it's if it's mainly going to be a web server to have the option to like read from standard in and like block on that that's not good like that's not that's not going to do anything they're not not going to do anything good um that's something that totally makes sense for a command line app but like for a web server it's like if you're ever reading from standard in something
但我认为，其实有一个非常充分的理由，让你不会总是只想使用这个命令行工具——除了可能会错过请求处理程序上潜在的 bump allocation（指针碰撞分配）带来的好处之外——那就是，如果它主要是一个网页服务器，我通常不希望我的网页服务器有能力去读取标准输入（standard in）并在其上阻塞。这不好——这不会……不会带来任何好结果。这对于命令行应用程序来说完全说得通，但对于网页服务器来说，如果你一直在读取标准输入，那可能说明
has probably gone wrong because there's not going to be a keyboard attached to that thing most likely yeah okay that makes sense to me you mentioned this before but it's worth highlighting again that you did say that there's going to be a facility for writing libraries.
出了问题，因为该设备极大概率不会连接键盘。是的，好吧，这对我来说说得通。你之前提到过这一点，但值得再次强调的是，你确实说过将来会有一个用于编写库的设施。
I don't know if you want to call them like platform generic libraries. Platform agnostic, yeah. If you're trying to write something generic enough that it should be able to work across a certain number of libraries, there's going to be a way or a number of platforms. There's going to be a way to do that in the future. You're not going to need n different libraries for n different platforms, which is, I think, the important part. Because a lot of the times applications, that's less when you care about like generosity versus when you're writing a library. You don't want to have to rewrite that library every single time you want a new application on a different platform. Yeah, totally.
我不知道你是否想称它们为平台通用库。平台无关库，是的。如果你试图编写一个足够通用的库，使其能够在一定数量的库（或平台）上工作，那么将来会有某种方法或一定数量的平台来实现这一点。你不需要为 N 个不同的平台编写 N 个不同的库，我认为这才是重要部分。因为很多时候，对于应用程序来说，通用性并不像你编写库时那么重要。你不希望每次想要在不同平台上运行新应用程序时，都必须重写那个库。是的，完全如此。
And like we have a really, that part of the design i'm super excited about it's just like it's not it's not the top priority to implement it right now because right now we're more in the like hey let's make sure that people can have a good experience like writing on the one platform there is no real ecosystem yet to to like to make you know platform agnostic um but but yeah like i i am very excited for once we do implement that feature because I think the design turned out really, really well. We could go into that, but I think we're already probably over on time again. I was going to say, I mean, we talked a lot about platforms and the continuation monad, a.k.a. task chaining IO stuff. Is there any, like, in the last couple minutes, though, if you just want to rapid-fire ecosystem or language stuff for people to be excited about if it exists or
而且我们有一个……设计的那个部分让我超级兴奋，只是……它目前并不是实现的最高优先级，因为现在我们更多地处于“嘿，让我们确保人们在使用单一平台编写时能有良好的体验”的阶段。目前还没有真正的生态系统来支持……去制造……平台无关的……但——是的，我非常期待一旦我们实现该功能，因为我认为设计结果真的、真的非常好。我们可以深入探讨这个，但我认为我们可能已经超时了。我本想说，我的意思是，我们讨论了很多关于平台和延续单子（continuation monad），也就是任务链式 I/O 的内容。在最后几分钟里，如果你们只是想快速浏览一下生态系统或语言方面的内容，让大家为现有的或
will exist, is there going to be a package manager? Yep, that's the plan. So you already can do packages using a URL thing. This is something I think, instead of rapid-firing, I'll just mention this one thing because I think it's pretty cool. So the way that you do packages today, we don't have a package index yet, like a searchable way to like discover them but you can
会有的，会有包管理器吗？是的，这就是计划。所以你已经可以通过 URL 来处理包了。我觉得与其语速飞快地讲一堆，不如只提这一件事，因为它真的很酷。目前我们处理包的方式是，我们还没有包索引，也就是那种可以搜索和发现包的方法，但你
already just like automatically download packages and we have as far as i know this is we're the only language to do it this way i think this design is awesome um and more languages should steal it um so basically the way that works is let's say i want to depend on luke's json parsing library the way that i do that is in my dependencies, I say, I'm depending on this JSON parsing library, and here is the URL for it. Now, the thing that we do that nobody else does is that when I specify that URL, the URL has to be in a particular format, which is that the end of the URL has to be a Blake3 hash of the contents of what's going to be downloaded from that URL.
已经可以像这样自动下载包了，据我所知，我们是唯一这样做的语言。我觉得这个设计太棒了，更多的语言应该借鉴它。基本上它的工作原理是这样的：假设我想依赖 Luke 的 JSON 解析库，我怎么做呢？在我的依赖项里，我说我依赖这个 JSON 解析库，这就是它的 URL。现在，我们做而其他人没做的事情是，当我指定那个 URL 时，URL 必须采用特定的格式，即 URL 的结尾必须是即将从该 URL 下载的内容的 Blake3 哈希值。
It has to be in the URL itself, which means that a couple of things. One is once I download it, first of all, we can cash it forever now if we want to, um, because we know that it's never going to change. If it does change, well, it's just going to fail the, the, the checks on when we download it because the hash is different. This also means that if that domain expires or gets compromised or hijacked or whatever, somebody like publishes a new version, even if I have never downloaded this thing before, like I'm just reading about this off a tutorial, I copy paste the code in, I've never used rock in my life. I have no, there's no infrastructure for this. There's no centralized anything. Like I just
它必须包含在 URL 本身中，这意味着有几点好处。第一，一旦我下载了它，首先，如果我们要的话，我们现在可以永远缓存它，因为我们知道它永远不会改变。如果它真的变了，好吧，当我们下载它时，它就会通不过检查，因为哈希值不同了。这也意味着，如果那个域名过期了、被黑了、被劫持了或者别的什么，某人发布了一个新版本，即使我以前从未下载过这东西，比如我只是从教程里读到它，我复制代码粘贴进去，我这辈子从没用过 Roc，我没有任何基础设施，没有任何中心化的东西。就像我
use that URL. Somebody took it over. I still don't get a bad package. The worst possible thing that can happen is I get an error. Um, from a security perspective, this is, I think unprecedented. I think every, every other language that uses URL based, um, uh, like packages, like lets you download a package direct from a URL as a dependency, either they're like not caching it, or even if they are, there's potentially some security vulnerability in there somewhere, or else there's like a, well, I should say and or, potentially there is also additionally a security vulnerability, unless there is some like centralized system that is like pro like proxy and caching all those
直接使用那个 URL。有人把它接管了，我也不会得到一个坏包。可能发生的最糟糕的事情就是我得到一个错误。从安全的角度来看，我认为这是空前的。我认为其他所有使用基于 URL 的包的语言，比如允许你直接从 URL 下载包作为依赖项的语言，要么没有缓存它，要么即使缓存了，那里也可能存在某种安全漏洞，或者说——我应该说“和/或”——可能还额外存在安全漏洞，除非有什么中心化的系统在代理和缓存所有这些
which i think is what go does but most languages i don't think do that like they don't have like a oh the last time anyone downloaded this we checked it out and it had this hash but the hash has changed now so beware you know it's it's potentially malicious but what i love about it is that it's just baked right into the ur URL so if anyone does want to they do successfully hijack the domain or whatever are otherwise able to publish that URL like what are they going to do like if they want to publish something that's different
我想 Go 语言就是这样的，但大多数语言我不认为它们会这样做。它们没有那种机制，比如“上次任何人下载这个时我们检查过，它有这个哈希值，但现在哈希值变了，所以要小心，它可能是有恶意的”。但我喜欢它的一点是，它直接嵌入到了 URL 中。所以如果真的有人想要这样做，他们成功劫持了域名或者什么的，或者能够发布那个 URL，他们能做什么呢？如果他们想发布一些不同的东西
they have to change the hash at which point the URL becomes different and that's not what people are going to be downloading so although I gotta say it makes for unattractive looking URLs. My first thought when I was looking at the tutorial, my first thought on, on the first example where it's got a package line was to tell you like, Hmm, maybe you could come up with a shorter URL for this.
他们必须改变哈希值，而在那个时候 URL 就会变得不同，而那并不是人们将要下载的东西。不过我必须说，这让 URL 看起来不太好看。当我浏览教程时，我的第一反应，对于第一个有 package 行的示例的第一反应是想对你说：“嗯，也许你可以为此想出一个更短的 URL。”
So, you know, I, that was my fear with this system. And I thought like, okay, well, we'll start with this and then we'll see like how many complaints we've gotten. Um, and then like, you know, about the URLs being really long. And then like maybe we can find, you know, some way to centralize and like shorten them. I'm not even joking. This just now is the first time I've ever heard anyone complain about that. And I'll tell you the reason that I think you'll never hear anybody complain because it it it looks bad in the tutorial
所以，你知道，这就是我对这个系统的担忧。我想，好吧，我们就从这个开始，然后看看我们会收到多少投诉。然后，你知道的，关于 URL 太长的问题。接着也许我们可以找到某种中心化并缩短它们的方法。我真的不是在开玩笑。这绝对是我第一次听到有人抱怨这个。而且我可以告诉你，我认为你永远不会听到任何人抱怨的原因是，它在教程里看起来很糟糕
um but nobody's ever typing it out people are just copying and pasting it exactly that's that's that's what i figured yeah and that's what i do too like i i also never like write it out by hand um but at the end of the day like i think that's fine like it has a lot of really nice technical properties and like if everyone's just going to copy paste it anyway and then never really look at it like i don't know seems fine i think it's fine i mean i guess i guess the thing that um uh you know eventually once you have a package manager then you can shorten a large part of the the url before the hash you know you can just have it be rot dot rock dot package or whatever yeah potentially i mean so there's that's a whole like long tangent discussion but um
嗯，但根本没有人手动敲出来，大家都是直接复制粘贴的。确实，确实，我也是这么想的。对，这也是我做的，比如我从来不会手写它。但归根结底，我觉得这挺好的。它有很多非常棒的技术特性，如果大家反正都要复制粘贴，而且从不真的去看它的话，我不知道，这看起来挺好的。我觉得挺好的。我的意思是，我猜……我猜那件事是……嗯，你知道，一旦你有了包管理器，你就可以缩短哈希值之前的大部分 URL，你知道的，你可以让它变成 rot.rock.package 之类的。对，有可能。所以，这是一个很长的话题讨论，但是
but yeah it is definitely something we potentially can do this has been a whirlwind of uh talking about everything from strange loop to rock and the beautiful thing about rock is unlike some of the languages we talk about you can actually go and try it out now that's true is it rock.org it's uh i wish we had that it's a rock-lang.org and i and i do want to say i think it's got a really good tutorial um you know and i when you were talking earlier about how it's a language that's meant to be easy to use, that was one of the first things that I got out of the tutorial, because the tutorial is a tutorial that I think is designed, approachable, like not too simple for somebody who has a lot of experience programming,
但是，是的，这绝对是我们潜在可以做的事情。这是一场旋风般的讨论，从 Strange Loop 到 Roc，而 Roc 美妙的地方在于，不像我们讨论过的一些语言，你现在就可以去亲自尝试一下。确实如此，是 rock.org 吗？它是……我希望我们拥有那个域名，它是 rock-lang.org。而且我想说，我觉得它有一个非常好的教程。你知道，当你之前谈到它是一门旨在易于使用的语言时，这是我从教程中得到的第一感受，因为这个教程的设计非常平易近人，对于有丰富编程经验的人来说不会太简单，
but I think also if i was even like just learning a programming language or if it's my first programming language i think um the tutorials well laid out for for a newcomer wow thank you so much i spent a bunch of time on it so it's great to hear is the tutorial a preview of the new style for the upcoming rock lang uh website because the rocklang.org just takes you to the what kind of looks like you have a markdown file and it's being rendered but the rock tutorial has got lots of colors lots of fonts um you got that great font that uh what is it permanent marker marker yeah um i'll give you a preview after we sign off of the of the new one um but uh
但我也觉得，如果我只是在学习一门编程语言，或者这是我的第一门编程语言，我觉得这个教程对于新来者来说布局非常合理。哇，太感谢了，我在上面花了很多时间，所以听到这个很高兴。这个教程是即将推出的 rock-lang 网站新风格的预览吗？因为 rocklang.org 现在的样子看起来就像你有一个 Markdown 文件并正在渲染它，但 Roc 教程有大量的颜色、大量的字体，你还有那个很棒的字体……叫什么来着？Permanent Marker？对，是的。我会在我们结束后给你预览一下新版本，但是
yeah by the time people hear this they'll just be like what are you talking about this is just what the whole website looks like yeah yeah i imagine there's going to be some uh orange site posts and buzz when the when the new website is up uh or maybe not maybe that's not in the the plan but if you don't i I'm sure someone will. Yeah. I mean, you can never tell these things, but I wouldn't be surprised. All right. Well, thank you for taking so much time out of your day to chat with us. I know the listeners.
是的，等人们听到这个的时候，他们会觉得“你在说什么，整个网站本来就是这个样子的”。对，对，我可以想象，当新网站上线时，会有一些“橙色网站”（Hacker News）的帖子和热议，或者也可能没有，也许这不在计划之中，但如果你不发，我相信别人也会发的。是的，我的意思是，你永远说不准这些事情，但我不会感到惊讶。好吧，谢谢你抽出这么多时间来和我们聊天。我知道听众们……
I mean, they love when we chat about cutting edge, bleeding edge programming language stuff. I mean, we love chatting about it, but our listeners, I think, also enjoy. And this is in the, I mean, like it's not a C++ successor initiative, but it's kind of in the space. If you're trying to be fast, you know, that's C++ adjacent, you know, even if it's a completely different paradigm.
我的意思是，当我们在聊那些最前沿、最尖端的编程语言时，他们非常喜欢。我的意思是，我们很喜欢聊这些，但我们的听众我想也很享受。这属于……我的意思是，它不是一个 C++ 的继承者计划，但它有点属于那个领域。如果你想追求速度，你知道的，它就与 C++ 邻近，即使它是一个完全不同的范式。
So interesting, you know, we might have some people on the Twitters or whatever the websites are called these days. Oh, yeah, there's a great way to end it. Where can people find you? some people on the Twitters or whatever the websites are called these days. Oh, yeah, there's a great way to end it. Where can people find you? Are you on the Twitters? Are you on the Mastodons?
太有趣了，你知道，我们可能会在推特或者现在这些网站叫什么名字的地方遇到一些人。哦，对，这真是一个很好的结尾方式。人们在哪里可以找到你？你用推特吗？你用长毛象（Mastodon）吗？
Or have you given up on social media sites? Or how can people reach out to you if they want to either get involved or ask questions? Yeah, I don't post a lot, but I am on Twitter, RT Feldman, also on GitHub. But if you want to get a hold of me, Twitter's a good place to do that. My DMs are open, so that's kind of the main thing that I use it for. That's what we like to hear. It's what we like to hear, because we hope the site doesn't go up in flames, but every week that passes, I have less and less faith in Bryce's conviction
或者你已经放弃使用社交媒体网站了？或者如果人们想参与进来或提问，该怎么联系你呢？是的，我不怎么发动态，但在 Twitter 上叫 RT Feldman，GitHub 上也有。不过如果你想联系我，Twitter 是个好地方。我的私信是开放的，所以这也是我使用它的主要用途。听起来真不错。听起来真不错，因为我们希望这个网站不会彻底崩盘，但随着时间的推移，我对布赖斯的坚定信念越来越缺乏信心了
that the site's going nowhere. I'm telling you, look, I'm just a stubborn man. We're going to outlast Elon. Okay. I mean, but is, is the site going to outlast Elon? That's the real question. We sure, we sure we will outlast him, but. I'm telling you any day now, man.
觉得这个网站哪儿也不会去。我跟你说，看吧，我只是个固执的人。我们会熬过马斯克的。好吧。我的意思是，这个网站能熬过马斯克吗？这才是真正的问题。我们当然，我们肯定能熬过他，但是。我跟你说，指不定哪天呢，伙计。
Any day now. All right. Well, thank you once again, Richard. Yeah. Expect, you know, some amount of uptick and interest whether that's one person or you know several um i'm sure there's going to be a few people checking out rock you can cut this out if you want kind of everybody can make a rock repo and get i mean we have several thousand listeners so uh if even a percentage of you did that, it would have to be even like if 5% of you went and did it, it would push it over the edge.
指不定哪天呢。好的。好吧，再次感谢你，理查德。是的。预计会有一定程度的兴趣增长，无论是1个人还是好几个人，嗯，我确信会有几个人去查看 Rock，如果你想的话可以把这段剪掉，基本上每个人都可以在 GitHub 上做一个 Rock 仓库，我的意思是，我们有好几千名听众，所以嗯，即使你们当中只有一小部分人这么做了，哪怕只有 5% 的人去做了，也足以让它取得突破。
I think it's kind of a silly GitHub thing. They don't just like allow you to like, like they should have a model where you can self-serve and do the work on your end to add the syntax. Oh, I think I think you do have to do it anyway. It's just they won't accept your PR unless... I think the reason they do that is probably to prevent extension squatting or something like that. Yeah, that is exactly what I was thinking. Because I think it's probably like there's 10,000 languages
我觉得这有点像是 GitHub 的一个傻气的小功能。他们不只是允许你像这样——他们应该推出一种模式，让你能够自主完成工作并在你那边添加语法。哦，我想我觉得你无论如何都得自己做。只是除非……我觉得他们之所以这么做，可能是为了防止扩展名被恶意抢占之类的吧。是的，这正是我所想的。因为我觉得大概有上万种语言
if you count everyone's pet language. I think even not counting the pet ones, it's in the thousands. And if you count the pet ones, then it's in the tens of thousands. And I guarantee you there'd be so many extension clashes. And a lot of languages, they choose more than one, right? Yeah. Okay. Fair enough.
如果把每个人的个人爱好语言都算上的话。我觉得即使不算那些个人爱好的语言，也有数千种。如果算上那些个人爱好的语言，那就是数以万计。我向你保证，会有这么多的扩展名冲突。而且很多语言，他们会选择不止一个，对吧？是的。好吧，有道理。
All right. Well, with that, signing off. And stay tuned, listener. I don't know what episode this is. We're probably on 156 to 159 inclusive, which means you might be hearing from Sean in episode 160, unless if that's right around Christmas time, in which case we might be bringing Zach back on and having our holiday special
好了，那么，就此告别了。听众朋友们请继续关注。我不知道这是第几集。我们大概在第 156 到第 159 集之间，这意味着你可能在第 160 集听到肖恩的声音，除非那时候正好赶上圣诞节，在这种情况下，我们可能会请扎克回来，做我们的节日特别节目
where we chat about random stuff, which is basically what we just do anyways. So anyways, thanks for coming on again, Richard, and good luck with Rock going forward. And hopefully we expect to see it, you know, being used by the whole entire world in a year in the future well thanks for having me i appreciate this is fun be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at adspthepodcast.com for links to anything we
我们在节目里闲聊各种杂七杂八的事情，这基本上也就是我们平时在做的事情。总之，再次感谢你来参加节目，理查德，祝 Rock 以后发展顺利。希望在未来的某一年，我们能看到它被全世界所有人使用。好吧，谢谢邀请，我很感激，这很有趣。请务必查看你的播客应用中的本期节目shownotes，或者访问 adspthepodcast.com，获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接
mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to the github discussion where you can leave comments thoughts and questions thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及 GitHub 讨论区的链接，你可以在那里留下评论、想法和问题。感谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。质量不高，数量管够。这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是充满混乱与知识点缀。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。